There was a woman who was dragged out of a town hall meeting in West Virginia
Simply for listing the corporate donors of politicians. I've jokingly but not I mean I guess I'm not really joking when I say it
politicians should display their corporate donors sort of like
NASCAR drivers do either on the front of their lecterns when they speak or in some other way
So that we know who's funding them, right, who has donated money to these politicians and Lisa Lucas went to the West
Virginia State House to testify against the bill
sponsored by the oil and gas industry called HB
4268 and it would let fossil fuel companies drill on the land of small
mineral owners without their consent and
What when I saw this I thought wait wait a second
I thought right-wingers were all about the sovereignty of land ownership and land owners
But they want a bill that would let
Corporations use the resources of that private land without consent? Doesn't really make sense part of that double standard from the right
But that's not the story here the story is that Lisa Lucas showed up, and she said hey listen um
the people who want this garbage bill
Got money from the companies that will profit from it
And she started reading who got the money from these oil companies and gas companies
And she was told to stop and eventually she was physically removed from the room. Check this out take a listen
I'd also like to point out that the people who are going to be speaking in favor of this bill are all going to be
paid by the industry and people who are going to be
voting on this bill are also often paid by the industry. For example, and I have to keep it short
simply because the public only gets a minute forty-five
while lobbyists can throw a gala at the Marriott
with whiskey and wine and talk for hours to the delegates so to keep it short
on the Judiciary Committee, Charlotte Lane
about
$10,000 from gas and oil interest including a AEP, Marathon, First Energy Dominion, EQT, and I could go on.
Next, let's talk about John Shott from Mercer: First Energy $2,000,
Appalachian Power $2,000, Steptoe and Johnson (that's a gas and oil law firm) $2,000,
Console Energy 1,000,
EQT 1,000, and I could go on.
Now let's talk about Jason Harshbarger--
Miss Lucas we asked no personal comments
be made if you don't talk about--These are not personal comments-- It is a personal comment
and I'm going to call you out of order if you're talking about individuals on the committee. So
If you would just address the bill, if not you know I asked you to please step down.
Jason Harshbarger took $3,500 out-- Remove--
40% of his money comes from gas and oil
including Dominion, EQT,
First Energy, --
(inaudible)
I'm not finished.-- Right.
Drag me off then.
People deserve someone who is going to fight for people and not corporations.
The next speaker would be Julie Archer-- Right so you heard the phrase personal comments right they said listen
You're allowed to talk about the bill, but not about specific people involved with the bill
This is a totally arbitrary way to try to suppress this type of information right I mean any reasonable person
Understands if you're involved with the bill you're a big part of the bill
But because that's considered personal she gets dragged off here. I actually think this is a great strategy for
political activism it can be really hard to show up at public comment periods at the local and state level and
Really make an impact if you show up
And you just start arguing about the politics of a bill you're probably not going to change a lot of minds
What about the idea of?
Showing up and doing exactly what?
Lisa Lucas did which is you come prepared with a list of who received money from whom and you say I want to tell you
That this is the amount of money that these people got from one side of this and that actually could could
Transcend party lines and appeal to everybody
Who is sort of against the crony capitalist system of political financing that we have make it about the money?
Because they don't want you to know that it's about the money put it front and center
And good for Lisa here, and by the way
She is running for in the Democratic primary in West Virginia 7th district
you can look her up, it's Lisa Lucas Lisa with two S's and
You know the the bad news is that the bill that Lisa was testifying against did make it out of committee
It's expected to pass both the House and Senate
And it's eventually expected to be signed into law by the governor Republican Jim Justice
And it's going to be disastrous for the environment
But congratulations to Lisa for doing something good there should be more of this
And I think that this this is something we should start doing a nationwide. We've got a great bonus show for you today
We're going to talk about
Westerners deported from Cambodia for their dancing we will talk about a big change to the way that oxycontin is going to be marketed
and also another
tipping related Fiasco this time involving a Florida
megachurch all those stories and more on today's bonus show don't miss the bonus show for Members Only at
david pakman.com slash membership and for patrons at the
$5 a month level at patreon.com slash david pakman show thanks for listening. Thanks for watching. We'll talk to you then